the upcoming fourth season of
yellowstone is hotly anticipated thanks
to the insane season three finale that
left the fates of several characters in
the balance
three dutton family members john beth
and casey were targeted in what appeared
to be coordinated assassination attempts
but they weren't the only ones who ended
the season in danger
in the season finale an injured jimmy
got the questionable advice to get back
in the saddle and start rodeo riding
again even though he was warned not to
by a doctor following a previous injury
wanting to prove himself he wrangled
himself a horse at the yellowstone ranch
with the intention to get back
up and ride after a few moments of
exhilarating bucking the situation
quickly got out of hand and jimmy was
thrown from the horse
hitting the ground with an audible crack
the last viewer saw of him that season
he was unconscious and possibly even
dead
now an otherwise innocuous instagram
snap from cole hauser who plays rip
wheeler has fans fretting about jimmy's
fate
houser took to instagram to post a
picture from the set of season 4 of
yellowstone
in the image several of hauser's cast
mates are seen on horseback including
most of the actors who portray the ranch
hands at the yellowstone ranch sometimes
referred to as the bunkhouse boys
however one yellowstone employee was
conspicuously absent
jimmy if you see that eight seconds yeah
jimmy
i saw several fans noticed the lanky
ranch hand's absence and seemed to have
made the connection to the potentially
fatal ending to a season three story arc
instagram user mac dixon commented
where's jimmy
with two looking eye emojis other users
wrote in with similar comments
taking jefferson white's absence from
the photo is nothing less than a portent
of doom for his character
whether he's dead debilitated or just
wasn't on set that day yellowstone fans
are nervous about the well-being of the
lovable wannabe rodeo rider
we won't know for sure what the future
holds for jimmy until season 4 premieres
but one fan does have a theory about his
fate
over at reddit yellowstone fan michael
jordan's toupee started a thread titled
thinking back on the season finale
something i noticed about jimmy
that something was a possibly telling
choice of headwear as the poster noted
he wasn't wearing his cowboy hat anymore
he was back to his baseball hat
indeed in the finale specifically the
scene where he's thrown from the horse
jimmy can be seen wearing a plain black
baseball cap instead of the cowboy hat
that he used to wear with pride
use her jetchet0516 chimed in to add you
know i noticed that too but didn't think
much of it
i wonder if it was a subtle hint his
cowboy days are truly over
yellowstone is a show that regularly
uses loaded imagery and metaphors so
it's not out of the realm of possibility
that jimmy's baseball cap might have
pretended that his time as a cowboy has
come to an end whether that means he's
severely injured or even dead
while fans on instagram are worried
about those possibilities others would
actually be fine with having less jimmy
on the show
in a reddit thread title jimmy's
character is cool but sacrificing main
characters for his storyline doesn't sit
right with me
users supremely paranoid had a bone to
pick with a possibly dead ranch hand
specifically they aren't a fan of
jimmy's storyline starting to eclipse
other characters on the show whose
narratives are more crucial to the
overall plot they wrote
i just don't care for jimmy they ditched
jaime for jimmy and he doesn't need that
much attention in my opinion
ultimately he's a cool character but i'm
not invested in bunkhouse boys of the
rodeo i'm invested in the duttons
they weren't the only ones harboring
resentments user montana jovi
said i so agree jimmy is an amusing side
character but the more prominence i give
him the less interested in him i am
meanwhile another user agreed adding
this is just an extra character arc i
don't need when i'm trying to figure out
rainwater beth rip and what's up with
jamie and his child that's on the way
however there was some jimmy defense
user complimentary badger opined that
even the fans can't let poor jimmy have
one good thing for once
for jimmy indeed these reddit users will
have to join those instagram fans and
waiting for season four
to see whether their favorite bunkhouse
boy survived
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one